ancestry.com has helped millions of  people discover their connections to  kings queens Vikings and more and now  you can trace your DNA to the man and  every child's heart Santa Claus being  descended from Santa Claus brings you a  world of benefits including unlimited  milk and cookies  breathtaking real estate and access to  strangers homes finding out if you're  related to Santa Claus is easy just take  a swab of your saliva spread it on a  hundred dollar bill to meet Jake beats  cows live in North Hollywood California  and I'll send it to ancestry.com  hundreds of people have already inquired  don't be fooled by other scammers find  out if you're descended from Santa Claus  with ancestry.com and me Jake pitch cows  can Jay Mitch Koski helping you find if  you're related to sand  [Applause]  you